one of the crucial things we're looking
out for is a sign
in the data on cases and deaths that
this vaccination program is starting to
have an impact and have a look at this
we might have
a sign at last now this shows you the
case numbers going all the way back to
the early phase
of the pandemic and then also death's
numbers as well gives you more of a
sense of where we were in the spring
last spring versus
this time around and one very crude way
of looking at this is you could just
look
uh at this at the rate at which deaths
are falling this time around
compared with last time around just to
give you a sense back of an envelope
sense
of whether we're doing better this time
than last time and here's what you see
so this line here shows you the rate at
which deaths fell
last time so that's the first wave and
how fast those deaths
fell from the peak all the way through
to those days
and here's what happened in the second
wave so that's where we are basically at
the moment
and you can see more or less in line
with the first the first wave but it is
moving i think deaths are falling a
little bit faster
this time around but there could be all
sorts of reasons for that so ideally
what you want to do
is to look at something called case
fatality rates and break it down
by age and that's what something that
researchers at oxford the center for
evidence-based medicine
have done what you've got here are case
fatality rates that's essentially
percentage chance
of a case turning into a death so the
higher uh
the older you are the higher that goes
all the way up to 90 to 120 you've got a
case totality rate of about 45 percent
the percentage chance
of dying from covert 19. now if the
vaccination program was successful
you would expect these bars here these
are the older people who are more likely
to be vaccinated 80 and over
you'd expect those to fall faster than
the other ones and here's what happened
look
they have fallen quite a lot and if i
just compress those bars into kind of
two segments here you can see under 80s
the case fatality rate since
early january has come down about 8 so
that's pretty good news but just look at
the over 80s
down by 30 percent over 30
that perhaps is the most compelling sign
we've got yet
that this vaccination program is working
because these are the people uh
many of whom have now been vaccinated
we're starting potentially to see those
effects
we'll continue to keep you updated on
this there is other good news it's not
often we get to show good news
on the screen at the moment but here's
some more good news this shows you
vaccinations the total cumulative number
of vaccinations that black line shows
you the target that the government is
aiming for
and you can just about make up it is
above target so vaccinating more
than expected more than it promised
previously so lots of good news there
everyone just hoping that that good news
continues